Let's consider another example
of continuous mass transfer.
Suppose we have a
truck, and that truck
has some type of plow.
And it's plowing snow.
And there's some type
of external force acting
on this truck, friction,
pushing the truck forward,
so let's just assume we
have some type of force, F,
on the truck.
And this is our snow.
And what's happening
in this problem
is that the truck connects--
picks up the snow.
And then, which is
at rest initially,
gets the snow up to
the speed of the truck.
And then the snow
falls off the plow.
So how do we model this problem?
Well, let's look at our
situation at time t.
And what we're going
to do is, we're
going to consider a certain
mass of snow, delta ms, that's
at rest.
And our truck, it's
a fixed mass truck,
is moving with a velocity
vt at time t, the truck.
So now, what happens
at time t plus delta t?
Well, the truck has picked
up the mass of the snow.
And the truck has now
changed its speed.
So that's at time
t plus delta t.
And now we want to write
down our momentum law.
So we have our external force.
Let's call this the
plus i hat direction.
We have our external force
is equal to the limit
as delta t goes to 0 of
the momentum at time t.
So we have t plus
delta t, so what
we have is the mass of the
truck plus delta ms times
v of t plus delta t.
And we have to subtract from it.
That's divided by delta t.
And we have to subtract from
this the moment at time t.
The snow is at
rest, only the truck
is moving, so we have minus
t of vt divided by delta t.
Now, as usual, we're going to
say that the truck has changed
its velocity in this interval.
And what we want to do now
is write out our equation.
We have F equals the limit
as delta t goes to 0.
Now when we write
this out, notice
that we're going to have
a number of terms here.
We have mt plus delta
ms times v plus delta v
of the truce-- that's the first
term-- divided by delta t.
And the second term is just
minus mass of the truck,
vt over delta t.
Well, first off, we
see some cancellations
between this term,
this, and that.
And what we're left with is
limit as delta t goes to 0.
We have the snow term, delta ms
over delta t times the truck.
Now, here we have
a term, which we're
going to analyze in a moment.
It has two infinitesimal
quantities.
And this term is
of second order,
which we're going to neglect.
And finally, we have
the term of mass
of the truck times
delta vt delta t.
So, neglecting this
second-order term
in differentials,
what we get when
we take the limit is, that
we get the force is the rate
that the snow is being picked
up times v of the truck,
plus mass of the truck,
times v truck, dt.
Now, the only issue that
we have to think about here
is about the rate that
the truck, the snow,
is being picked up.
So that's our last
consideration,
but this will be our
differential equation
for adding mass,
continually, to a system.
So, when we found our equations
for describing the rate
that the truck changes its
speed-- the snowplow when it's
pushing snow away, we
wrote down our equation
in terms of the external force
on the truck, the rate that
snow is being picked up
by the truck, the velocity
of the truck, the
mass of the truck,
the rate of change of
velocity of the truck.
If we multiply our
equation through by dt,
we have the following equation.
And now what we
want to consider is
we want to focus on how
much dms is picked up
in our infinitesimal time, dt.
So one way to think about that
is, let's do a little drawing.
So here's our truck.
And let's say at time t--
the plow is right here,
so here's the picture at time t.
And let's draw some snow here.
Here in New England
we have lots of snow.
And at time t plus
delta t, the truck
has moved a certain distance.
And so, this quantity
is the amount of snow
that's picked up by the
truck and displaced.
Now, the truck has moved a
distance v truck delta t.
And so, we can identify the
delta ms, which in the limit
will be dms, is equal to
the density of snow times
the cross sectional
area of the plow,
times the length v
of truck delta t.
And so now we have an
expression for the rate
that the mass is being picked
up in this time interval.
And we can write that
in the following way.
That we see that our
differential equation
Fdt equals dms,
which is rho A vt,
times dt-- This will
be a small interval,
we're taking a limit now--
times another vt plus mt dvt.
Now, we can bring this term
over to the other side.
And so we have F
minus rho A vt squared
times dt equals the mass
of the truck times dvt.
And the mass of the truck,
in this case, is fixed.
Why?
Because when the snow
gets into the truck,
at the end of this
delta t time interval,
it gets displaced to the side.
So this is an equation that
we can separate and integrate.
So we have dt is equal to
mt divided by F minus rho
A vt squared dvt,
and we integrate
from some initial time
and some final time.
And here, we're
integrating from v of truck
from some t initial
time to some final time.
And that's our integral version
for our-- finding the velocity.
This interval is an interval
that's not hard to do,
that you should
try as an exercise
in elementary calculus.